oh no no no we don't even know what's
down there freshmen that's what Stalin
come on where's your sense mr. Chang
see would I tell you whatever than that
to come straight to hidden for 2,000
years
the Mattoon it's produced next
the hieroglyph said she was named
ominous chosen to be Egypt's next Queen
but her thirst for power led her down a
darker path one that had to be stopped
because of your actions
this ancient power has returned
[Music]
you are alive because you were chosen
sure by what evil mr. Morrow the
ultimate evil
legend has actually been unimaginable
power I'm sure getting him to retain
them
she will not stop
until she has remade our world into her
gown I know you could not he gave is the
only pirate ship without inspection I
thought there was a moment you can't run
[Music]
you can't escape she's got plans for you
so mommy not a lot of silicon old you
it had this idea of creating a zero-g
sequence for some time
Tom said yeah we're going to for real
we're going to get on a real plane and
we're going to crash it and I thought
this is never going to happen
there's a real physical challenge in
doing a zero-g it was really developed
for the Apollo missions we inject the
aircraft into an orbit you are in 3/4
you are waited
it's a real set built inside of real
planes that's actually really going to
go 25,000 foot up and does zero gravity
and we had to prepare as best we could
but then we don't quite know exactly
what's going to happen
we wanted to be wild and violence and
spontaneous for an audience they're just
seeing it's happening in real time
there's no edit it's there that's a good
[Music]
experience this historic stunt in
virtual reality at the Austin Convention
Center ballroom be
you